so let's call kiyosaki here
ken kiyosaki robert kiyosaki if you're
watching this guys share this uh podcast
with others
so they can catch it a moment here with
kiyosaki
where's your guess he is hawaii uh he's
probably going to be in arizona
which is very good because he'll give
perspective on what's going on arizona
hello
is this robert kiyosaki it is it is
how are you good is this patrick it is
patrick how you doing
oh man you have no i was just thinking
about you
when christina my assistant said you
want to
do this interview says timing is perfect
well it's great to have you on we got a
few thousand people live right now with
us
uh forty five hundred forty five hundred
people that are live with us right now
on the podcast
and uh you know i know you always have
some unique perspective on what's going
on and i believe
i think you are i think you're in
phoenix arizona so your state
matters a lot so robert what are your
thoughts with what's going on right now
with the election
well patrick this was more than an
election
this was a turning of america
and um i've been watching your work and
all this you and i are saying the same
things
so um i think we're going
we're sliding into socialism
and as you know because you have the
book of marx and anne ran
and ran on your portrait behind me
[Music]
we're going communist and
um the reason i was thinking about you
the other day
is because i can feel your pain i mean
you're not bad for an army guy
yeah and my temper yeah i was
i was watching you with britney kaiser
and richard wall you know the socialists
and that guy uh is that uh lucian
trust god lucian truscott your boy yeah
and uh and then i just want to repeat
i'm just i'm just going to give
give your audience back what you've been
saying to everybody because i agree with
it
you say biden is not going to read your
book for you
biden is not going to teach you a new
skill
but i am afraid that you're going to
need them
because this election was more than an
election this is what i fought against i
went to vietnam twice as a marine
and i fought against what's happening in
america i fought against socialism and
communism
and it's coming into this country so i
hate to be so pessimistic
on the other side i agree with you is
what he can do about it
so that's really my position i mean
arizona is horrible you have no idea
there was this prophet does this 501 c 3
came out of oregon and they changed our
state constitution
under the guise of they said oh we're
going to give the money to the school
teachers not giving the money to the
school teachers
because my you know my friend is the
governor he says this is bs
they basically changed the constitution
to raise the taxes on the rich
that's all it was nothing to do with
school teachers
but my friend patrick this is socialism
and communism everything you talk about
you left iran
and you come to america and it's
following us i'm afraid
that's what i want to say you you think
so so the other part i want to ask
somebody like you i appreciate that the
other thing i want to ask somebody like
you is
what do you think about all this talk
where if it goes to the supreme court
with voter fraud trump's still going to
be the president it's not going to be
biden
what do you think is going to happen are
you are you looking at this as
look biden's going to be the president
people have to just realize he's the
president or there is a chance that
potentially after what giuliani and some
of the other guys could get involved in
this could change it's possible but it's
an out
uh it's possible but
you know what let me tell you what i'm
really really upset about
is silicon valley is big brother
if you know what i mean they control the
media and i'm not saying because i hear
it on the news is i've been censored so
many times i've seen i've texted you i
said yeah how do you get out of
saying what you say how how in the world
are we censored again
why are we censored you know i you know
donald trump is my friend his two sons
and i are really good friends
when i mention them on my tweets i got i
got taken off
mm-hmm how could it sense for me for
talking
you know i was we were we had a radio
show with eric trump we were talking
about how
how they're keeping their hotels filled
now that coabit 19 emptied them
and it all it was nothing political but
but
twitter just took it off
i i just can't believe this patrick
that's communism
that's censorship that's first amendment
freedom of assembly freedom of speech
freedom of religion is gone that's what
i'm upset about this was more than an
election my friend
it's what you and i fought against
and i i it makes me sick to my guts
so i agree 100 percent about it is bite
is not going to read a book
what you say and binance bible's not
going to teach you new skills i see a
lot of opportunity coming
but you're not but for those who do
nothing you know evil persists when good
men do nothing
and evil will persist hey robert tom
zenner here from jet set magazine
back in the day i was the executive
editor for jet set and all the great hey
how you doing good
good to talk to you you know my theory
robert is um
the hatred for trump has just superseded
any rational thinking and i'm just
curious your perspective about what
happened because they're smart people
smart people that have money that want
to keep their money that are capitalist
that are pro-biden and and have to know
what's down the pike
with what's coming with him how how do
you think this country got so stupid
so fast well that's why i was
talking to my friend here patrick you
know when i stepped off the plane at
norton air force base in january 3rd
1973 i got hit by rotten eggs and spit
and all that stuff
and that was a turning of america
socialists took over they took over the
education system
and then you know patrick when you
interviewed that guy i forget his name
now but
those two teachers and all this stuff
they're hardcore socialists
i know i know because my family are
socialists they're called school
teachers
they think they believe in robin hood
economics
take from the rich and put it in your
pocket
and that's why i'm saying i'm afraid
fighting is not going to solve the
problems the problems are going to get
worse
because it starts in our education
system and
you know patrick knows i'm i keep asking
the same question why don't they teach
us about money in school
but i found out it's not a mistake it's
not a mistake
you're saying it's not a mistake they
don't teach money in school you're
saying it's not a mistake that they
don't teach money in school it's
intentional right
no i i you know i read this book by um
dr r buckminster fuller you know it was
the grunts of giants you know grind
stands for girls universal cash eyes
is how the altruist steal our money
and so i read that in 83 then i
understood my rich dad my rich dad was a
man without any education but he was a
capitalist
my poor dad was a very good man but he
was a school teacher
head of education phd and for university
all
the pedigrees he knew nothing about
money
and so my poor dad and my rich dad grew
up in hawaii they always argue
you know i mean one was head of the head
of the teachers union the
school system and the government and my
rich dad was a hardcore capitalist just
leave me alone just leave me alone
but they never saw eye to eye and i
think that's the problem so
you know patrick how you handle brittany
kaiser uh of cambridge analytics
i was surprised you didn't tear her head
off
i mean i said man you got more control
than me because as a marine i would just
come after her
you know i remember what she said she
said she says why do you hate trump so
much she says well because i worked on
his campaign
and then you asked us what about hillary
says i don't know anything about hillary
so she based all of her decisions based
upon
getting to look under the sheets at
trump but she never saw the corruptions
that obama
and clinton's i mean they're some of the
biggest criminals going
you know they go into politics broke and
they come out near billionaires
i should tell you something trump didn't
have to steal because he already already
got his money
uh i think that's the problem it is
exactly
socialism i mean capitalism going to
socialism
and i went to military school also
military schools
you know what we're taught is military
economics
but was taught i went to my mba the mba
program is socialist economics that's
keynesian and malthusian economics
but the capitalist economics is austrian
which is mises
and ron paul and
ron you know capitalist economics would
not allow
you know capitalist economics which is
mises or austrian
is based based upon uh saint thomas of
aquinas
and it was legal moral and ethical
economics when you go to keynesian and
malthusian
it's just print as much as you want and
take care of people
and then military economics what we had
to look at went to the school in new
york
we had to look at the body counts who
has killed the most people in history
socialists hitler killed 18 million
people six million jews
stalin twenty seven million tongue 46
million
the body count is only going to start
now you guys that's what i'm that's what
i'm concerned though so i studied
military economics
socialist economics which is keynesian
and malthusian
and then capitalist economics which is
austrian school which is why
i like gold silver and bitcoin good
segue to gold
uh silver and bitcoin uh robert much
respect this is adam sosnick leader of
the soyboy mafia here on the uh the
podcast
um question for you because obviously
we're you're really honing in on
politics here
when i think of you i think of economics
i think of
financial literacy i think i mean i read
rich dad poor dad when i was
in college i i'd like to hone in on uh
financial questions and i'll leave the
political stuff to
to pat and tom um i've actually read
recently or re-read rich dad poor dad
the cash flow quadrant
speak to our audience a little bit these
days a couple questions on something
that i
say i host valuetainment economics one
of the things that
inspired me to even start what i talk
about is they truly do not teach
financial literacy in school i went all
throughout
high school college got degrees yadda
yadda knew nothing couldn't even spell
401k
by the time i got my first job so now i
try to
break down money in a language that
everyone can understand here's my
question to you
um these days you said that you're all
about bitcoin
gold silver commodities and i know i i
guess ultimately my question is
can you get wealthy these days without
investing in real estate i know real
estate and being at tax advantage real
estate
is a major um aspect of what you talk
about
forget about politics for a second if
you would and talk just economics what
young
people our audience is basically 21 to
35 on average a little bit older a
little bit younger
talk to them where should they be
looking where should they be looking to
put their money where should they be
investing
give the lay of the land specifically
economically
well i i'm a hard advocate for financial
education so when i came back from
vietnam in 783
i started taking real estate investment
courses
because it's not about real estate as
you guys know in 781 nixon took the
dollar off the gold standard
and i was flying in vietnam at the time
and
what that meant to me was that the
dollar became debt
and taxes so the reason i
invest in real estate is just last week
i borrowed 28 million dollars
it's not not trump money but 28 million
dollars is tax-free
debt and with that i acquire assets
and because i'm using debt to acquire
real estate i pay no taxes
so that's what that's what my rich dad
taught me to do so there's more
opportunity ever before but if all you
have is an
mba you can't see what i see
that's why trump and i have good friends
they they nail him
for not paying taxes well that's how
stupid
those reporters are recently doesn't pay
taxes he doesn't have an income
you know he turned in his presidential
salary
so he only paid 750 dollars in taxes
i don't pay any money in taxes because i
use
debt and i depreciate i appreciate i
appreciate and amortize my real estate
that's the game
so i'm not about real estate it's about
tax debt and taxes i can borrow as much
as i like tax free
you know i asked i asked these young
people i said i just borrowed 27 million
dollars how long would it take you to
save 27 million
they don't have any idea they can't
because they're going to get taxed at 50
percent
has to save 54 million dollars to borrow
27 million
i mean to get 20 net money yeah so it's
always debt in taxes
and that's what happened in 71 with
nixon taking a dollar off the gold
standard i don't huge kids that
regarding real estate what these guys
are saying is get out of debt get out of
debt
and save money i mean are you kidding me
why don't you save money when they're
printing it and they're dropping
interest rates to negative interest
rates
you got to be crazy robert what would
you tell
a pet you had some guys on your show
that were
pretty high up there from the fed they
were saying i teach people to save money
i said you guys are criminals why would
you save
money when they're printing it and the
interest rates are going to go sub-zero
you got to be crazy
robert follow-up question on the saving
money uh component
um 78 of americans are living paycheck
to paycheck
50 of americans don't have 500
in their bank account 40 of americans
literally do not have a thousand dollars
uh period why do you think saving money
is bad and what would you tell those
americans who have no money would you
tell them to invest in real estate with
the money they don't have
how would you answer those people i
wouldn't
invest in real estate unless you're
willing to study
if you're not willing to study get a
401k and die
that's all i can say to you you're
playing right into the hands of wall
street
i don't have any stocks and i don't save
money because i don't need to
but that's you robert you're worth you
know what 100 million dollars maybe more
or less depending on the day i don't
know your net worth
but speak to every american out there or
anyone for that matter who has a
thousand dollars in the bank
five thousand dollars at the bank
believe me if i had 10 million dollars
100 million dollars i'd be right there
with you buddy but if i have five
thousand dollars to my name
how could i possibly listen to you when
you say
don't save money this is my question to
you and i'm not being combative
i want my audience to understand i i
understand i i catch this
all the time and i'm saying you don't
need money that's the biggest
thing about it i just go to my bank and
i borrow it
but i have to show the banker i know
what i'm talking about i have financial
statements i have track records
nice i you know i i have a track record
and patrick said at best when he says
you know bina is not going to read the
book for you
and he's not going to teach you the
skills so
if you don't have any financial
education get
401k i was going to say the f and 4 when
you get in touch one
but that's the best for most people and
then save money
but i wouldn't do that and that's why
you know i've caught hell
rich dad port has been almost 25 years
now i'm still number one that's awesome
i love it but the academic elite you
know uh i got turned down by every book
publisher in new york to say you don't
know what you're talking about
your health i said your house is not an
asset savers are losers and the rich
don't work for money
then that was just that i got hammered
for that but i still i won't stop i mean
i don't need money i can borrow it
because
money became debt in 1971 when nixon
took the dollar
off the gold standard and so that's
austrian economics versus social
economics
versus military economics and that's
requires study and if you're not willing
to study
save money go to school become a doctor
and pay exorbitant taxes
and put your money in a 401k or an ira
and you guys all know
the pension plans are broke all over
america hey robert
as as close as you might buy that cannot
solve the problems
he cannot solve the problems yup hey
robert as close as you are to donald
trump you've written books together you
guys are very tight you know what's
going on with him
two things number one how pissed off is
he right now how hard is he going to
fight this
and take it as far as he needs to in
your opinion and
if he doesn't win would he come back in
2024 in your opinion
that i really don't know when we're
we're good friends his sons and i are
better friends
and i you know i'm just in con i'm just
in mourning with them that's all i'm at
right now
i can't speak for him so they're not in
how about the sons how about don junior
are they
pretty much a fighting mode right now
yeah they're fighters but um
let me just let me just say when silicon
valley can censor the world as
big brother we have bigger problems than
trump
you know when when i get my tweets taken
down my company is censored
by silicon valley but but you know bezos
is washington post they called me a
racist
i got accused of being a racist i'm
going are you kidding me
and and then they basically shut down
the rich dad website
that was uh facebook what is going on
with this country
we got bigger problems than trump so
that's why i started this whole thing
it was more than an election it was it
was we're shifting from capitalism
to socialism to karl marx
the communist manifesto that sits on
patrick's
desk and his painting and this is the
real question i thought patrick that was
fantastic
and ran the question is where am i going
to hide my money went into hiding a long
time ago
why did you say uh the did you say the
trump boys are in mourning
no no no they're they're angry i mean i
i i
i talked to him about two weeks ago just
as we're going
you said those words i just i don't know
if i misheard you yeah i'm i'm in
mourning too i just i just
i'm in mourning for america so do you
think that trump does not have any
um you don't think he's gonna be able to
turn the ship around
and win any of these court battles like
what do you mean by mourning
let me just say it again when zuckerberg
runs america through fake media and
social media
we have bigger problems than trump
we are now a totalitarian state we're a
big brother
orwell that's what i'm saying we have
such big problems right now so
airtime patrick talked about running
away from iran and going to germany and
coming to america
well the problem is those hippies that
spit on me back in 1973
they're now school teachers or labor
union people wow
or they are they teaching those kids who
go into silicon valley
who believe in equality
you know i i'm all for equality but
don't take my money
and so the problem is our educational
system
and so when zuckerberg i mean our rich
dad
we don't say much i don't dare say much
i mean i i text
i text patrick all every time i go
patrick how did you get away with that
one
but but i'm trying to say something you
guys
the first amendment was taken away from
us
by silicon valley by zuckerberg bezos
and those guys
that's the problem that's a bigger
problem than trump trying to fight again
he got crushed by social media
how do we turn this around robert why do
we steer this ship in the right
direction
and ran you said it
on your program as i i went into hiding
the producers go into a 1957
show of the classic atlas shrugged the
producers go into hiding
so i'm in hiding in plain sight so i
look like everybody else
but i'm not going to pay the taxes
legally i'm not going to keep my money
in this country
legally i don't save dollars legally
i use gold silver and bitcoin as uh
retainers of wealth i refuse to let the
fed and the treasury
steal my wealth robert where do you see
bitcoin in the next five years
i i don't really know because i was late
to the party and i started buying it at
9 200.
i think today is at 15. you weren't that
late if you bought it in at 9 200.
well i i i tried to buy it at 20 but
somehow my wife talked me out of it
which was good
when did you buy it at 9 200
uh about four or five a while ago
i mean i'm buying i'm buying more okay
but the pop this is not what i'm saying
to you guys a lot
i don't really know bitcoin that well
but i know this as the price of bitcoin
goes up the supply goes down
whereas with the us dollar as the price
the value of the dollar goes down the
supply goes
up so that's why i'll mention anything
with daniel d
and martino bush you should just save
money i said
are you nuts can't you see what's
happening
robert that's what i'm saying can't you
see what's happening
did you say you don't own any stock at
all in the stock market whatsoever
i own gold mining shares but that's your
only form of um
equities yeah yeah i don't need stocks
i don't and i have a lot of real estate
i'm probably a billionaire in debt
i practice what i preach and do you
think i
i borrow to buy real estate and i don't
buy
commercial i buy apartment houses
residential and then because i do that
the government gives me tax breaks and
so i pay no taxes
that's the game that's why i was
teaching at richard
the power of corporations robert
question for you
with current times on what's going on
for me i'm always uh
watching to see who's who's got the most
influence right now under a
biden administration who become the most
powerful people in america if you were
to say
here's a five names to watch very
closely that could
influence censorship etc etc whatever it
may be
who would those five names be that
you're watching very closely with abide
in an
administration zuckerberg
schmidt uh the new president you know is
kamala harris
and are you you patrick you mention them
all the time
they work out of silicon valley
i hate to say that but that's big
brother that was orwell i think
orwell or oxley
so look at george floyd it was a tragic
death but
what aldous huxley said was that we
would have designer drugs
so when when george floyd went down he
had coveted and he had
oxycontin or something in his system so
we're drugged out
you know portland oregon just dropped
holding hard drugs to traffic 500 bucks
so we're becoming this drugged out
society
so the the i'm just giving patrick's
words back to him
it's karl marx and rand uh all there was
moxley
orwell and this guy bucky fuller they
you could see this stuff coming
it's here and that's why i said this
election was more than an election
it was a turning of america from
capitalism to socialism
and socialism always leads to please
with totalitarianism
so i went to military school in new york
and we measured
we measured economics and body counts
so i was let me say that again this is
history
hitler murdered 18 million people 6
million jews
stalin was 27 million and they estimate
that
mile killed 46 million
and that's what's coming so hopefully it
doesn't happen
but if you look at history that's what
we should learn from history but we
don't teach that economics in schools we
teach socialist economics
keynesian malthusian versus
austrian school mises and ron paul
and it's in our school system that's all
i'm saying and that's why
there's no financial education in
schools you know who pays the highest
taxes are doctors and lawyers
guys like trump and i don't pay taxes
because we're real estate guys
we use debt and we don't pay taxes and
that's the game that's what i wrote
about rich dad poor dad
robert you typically make some kind of
market predictions i'll make this the
last question we'll let you go back to
your business to what you were doing
and hopefully we'll have you back on on
other podcasts in the future
is any prediction you're going to make
to the market the next 6
12 24 48 months yeah
you watch this you know this grand new
deal
it's going to become the hottest
properties you can buy
because what's going to happen these
socialists going to get in there they're
going to push for solar and all that
stuff
and unfortunately you know the poor
people the people who are hardcore
socialists will not participate
but already i'm i'm i'm i'm investing in
green energy because it's going to be
the biggest thing because they're going
to push tax to pay our dollars into it
any specific any specific uh uh
uh uh names or companies or or
funds that you're looking at well
there's this guy out of vancouver as a
friend of mine
like like you patrick's name's marin
katusa m-a-r-i-n-t-k-t-k-a-t
usa he's probably the brightest guy you
see
he's a calculus teacher who saw the
lights saw the lights of capitalism
but he's figuring it out nice so uh he
and i invest together and things like
this but
i've always been a grainy it just wasn't
any money in it now there's a lot of
money coming into it but it's coming
from taxpayer dollars
robert speaking of uh green energy what
about
uh literal green energy cannabis stocks
do you
is that something you look at at all no
i
i'm a marine man i don't do drugs you
know i really don't i don't i
didn't ask you i didn't ask if you did
green i asked about
green uh marijuana cannabis stocks that
seem to be skyrocketing these days
no no no no i have my morals you would
not touch that
morally no i don't cheat on my wife
you know not a democrat that's good
[Laughter]
only democrats cheat on their wives is
that what you said i don't know
you know you know what i'm talking about
it's just like
i know look at donald trump he's never
cheated on his wife he's doing great
if you haven't already figured out our
buddy adam here cannot stand
president trump i think i think you
already figured that out yeah but i like
you robert i i
just is it possible to vote for biden
and still believe in capitalism
no tom i asked an expert sorry um
but it's really kamala harris she's the
president
you know he's just he's just a dead man
walking
so she's running the country oh my gosh
she is going to
you know see trump swore i mean we we
all know the battle is coming down
into the senate that's what the battle
is going to be
200 million bucks yeah i i wish you know
if a perfect world i wish trump had won
but but he still has got a shot though
robert
the problems are so big biden cannot
solve them
so the problems are not going to go away
the problems are going to get
bigger so that's why patrick
and ren ayn rand's book atlas shrugged
should be the bible right now
because the other book is marxist
communist manifesto you said all in your
program i'm just giving your words back
to you
well no i appreciate that it's good it's
coming from you
[Laughter]
well robert thank you so much i said the
other day i was i was saying i was
really depressed
i said i wonder what patrick and then
christina said hey
patrick manciano's program oh there must
be a god someplace
let me ask you are you are you in hawaii
are you staying in phoenix right now
no i'm back i'm out in uh south carolina
okay got it let me tell you why
because iran says the capitalists or
producers go into hiding i'm hiding
on a private island with other producers
hiding
if it's the island i think you're on
you're on a good island
well it's mostly marines living out here
i mean i mean
four stars and stuff like that robert
last question
um if you if you don't mind what should
our listeners who own stock just average
people you know maybe they own
50 000 a hundred thousand maybe that's
their net worth and stocks
what should they do with their stock i
i really don't i don't give financial
advice you know like i
i i'm just trying to say something i i
just got started in bitcoin
and i hope i have lots and lots of gold
and silver
i don't store it inside the country let
me just tell you that much
hmm so what you do is up to you you can
make you know and buffett makes money in
stocks and
some guys make money in stocks i just
don't like stocks
because they're manipulated fair enough
does that make sense to you
i want to control my destiny patrick you
said it buy them it's not going to read
the book for you
and bina is not going to teach you the
skills
[Laughter]
that is true neither one of these guys
guys are you know you gotta you gotta
pick it up and go do it yourself
it's just gonna be interesting what
happens the next four years that's the
biggest thing it's gonna be very very
interesting to see what happens the next
four years
robert thank you so much for being a
guest today we will definitely invite
you back on if you're open to we'd love
to have you back on again
on the podcast hey man you have a call
for an army guy you got a lot of guts
much love to you robert thank you so
much okay take care bye bye
[Music]